Guten Tag, ich heiße Mustafa Tavakse. Ich bin heute Ihr zuständiger Arzt.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeber führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Natürlich, gerne.
Kursmatla, zuerst brauche ich Ihre persönlichen Daten.
Und dann kommen wir zu Ihren aktuellen Bescheid.
Falls Sie etwas nicht verstanden haben, bitte geben Sie mir Bescheid. Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Sabine Krüger.
Könnten Sie bitte mir Ihren Vornamen und Nachnamen langsamer bestäben?
Mein Vornamen ist S.V. Siegfried, A. wie Anton, B. wie Bertha, E. wie Ida, N. wie Nordpol, E. wie Emil.
Mein Nachname ist Krüger, K. wie Konrad, R. wie Richard, Ü wie Ü, G. wie Gustav, E. wie Emil, R. wie Richard.
Krüger, ja.
Frau Krüger, wie alt sind Sie? Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 46 Jahre alt. Ich bin geboren am 22. September 1979.
20. September 1979?
1979.
1972.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie, Frau Krüger?
Ich bin 1,72 Meter groß und wiege ungefähr 70 Kilogramm.
70 Kilogramm. Okay.
Frau Krüger, was fühlt Sie heute zu uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich komme dazu, weil ich seit mehreren Wochen nicht mehr belastbar bin.
Ich bin sehr schnell aus Atem, habe Schwindel, habe Herzrasen und bin sehr müde.
Können Sie bitte mir langsam wiederholen, erklären?
Ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich seit mehreren Wochen sehr schnell aus der Puste bin.
Ich habe bei Belastung Luftnot.
Ich habe Schwindel, ich habe sehr schnell Herzrasen und ich bin sehr müde.
Schwindel, ja.
Sind Ihre Beschwerden zum ersten Mal aufgetreten? Hatten Sie eigentlich auch Beschwerde in der Vergangenheit?
Das hatte ich noch nie, nein.
Erstes Mal.
Seit mehreren Wochen.
Sind Ihre Beschwerden langsam aufgetreten oder plötzlich?
Langsam.
Langsam, ja.
Immer, Sie leiden unter diesen Beschwerden, anhalten.
Seit ein paar Wochen.
Seit ein paar Wochen, ja.
Haben Sie diesen anderen Arzt aufgesucht?
Noch nicht, nein.
Ja, Sie haben schon gesagt Hüsten.
Ich habe keine Hüsten, nein.
Entschuldigung, ich habe es fast verstanden.
Atemnot.
Wenn ich mich belaste, bin ich sehr schnell aus der Puste.
Habe Sie auch Hüsten?
Ich habe keine Hüsten, nein.
Ich wiederhole nochmal, was ich habe.
Wenn ich mich belaste, habe ich Luftnot.
Ich habe Schwindel, ich habe sehr schnell Herzrasen und ich bin sehr müde.
Sehr müde, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Brust?
Nein.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für diese Beschwerden?
Wenn ich mich belaste, ja.
Nein, ich meine, nur Belastung, ja.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Schüttefrosnachschweiß?
Leiden Sie unter Geschwollen?
Nein.
Leiden Sie unter Nervosität?
Schüttefrosnachschweiß?
Nein.
Haben Sie bei Veränderung beim Wasserlassen Stuhlgang?
Leiden Sie unter Durchfall oder Verstofe?
Nein.
Sie haben schon gesagt Herzrasen.
Auch haben Sie Herzklopfen?
Was ist das Unterstehende?
Ja.
Herzrasen fühlen sich sehr schnell.
Herzklopfen bedeutet, dass sie sehr schnell in den Herzen sind.
Sie fühlen sich sehr stark.
Nein, wenn ich mich belaste, habe ich Herz haben.
Herzrasen.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nein.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Gewicht verloren?
Nein, auch nicht.
Oder zu genommen haben Sie Gewicht?
Ich bin immer gleich ungefähr, immer bei 70 kg.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Zu gut, ja. Zu gut.
Ich schlafe sehr viel, weil ich sehr müde bin.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Gut, finde ich sehr gut.
Sehr gut.
Ok.
Hatten Sie Schwinde oder Bewusstsein verloren?
Nein.
Leiden Sie unter Niedergeschlagenheit?
Oder wie fühlen Sie sich?
Müde.
Ja, müde.
Ich meine, leiden Sie unter depressiver Stimmung?
Ja, ja.
Geschlecht ist normal.
Eigentlich nicht, nein.
Ja, normal.
Leiden Sie unter anderen Beschwerden?
Von denen, die ich gerade genannt habe.
Ok.
Leiden Sie unter Kopfschmerzen?
Manchmal.
Kopfschmerzen.
Ok.
Wurde bei Ihnen eine Herzerkrankung festgestellt oder diagnostiziert?
Noch nie.
Ok.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine Reise gemacht?
Nein, letztes Jahr im Sommer.
Ja.
Ok.
Frau Krüge, ist Ihre Monatsblutung regelmäßig?
Verstärkt.
Verstärkt?
Ja.
Leiden Sie an einer chronischen Erkrankung?
Ja, wissen Sie?
Nein.
Dauerhafte, zum Beispiel, Zuckerkrankheit?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nehmen Sie auch keine Medikamente ein?
Keine Medikamente.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Zuletzt vor vielen Jahren habe ich die Mandeln entfernt bekommen.
Wann war ich?
Ich war 10 Jahre alt.
10 Jahre alt.
Ich bemerke mich.
Was hatten Sie noch?
Wie bitte?
Hatten Sie auch eine andere Operation?
Nein.
Ok.
Sind Ihnen Allergien und Verträglichkeiten bekannt?
Keine.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben keine Medikamente.
Sind Sie vorständig geimpft gegen Kinderkrankheiten?
Ja.
Und auch Covid-19-Influenza?
Zuletzt habe ich mich vor zwei Jahren impfen lassen.
Vor zwei Jahren.
Ok.
Influenza?
Das ist die Grippeimpfung, oder?
Ja, echte Grippe.
Nein, da habe ich mich impfen lassen.
Möchte ich auch nicht.
Ok.
Frau Kruger, rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche nicht, nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ganz selten.
Vielleicht ein oder zwei Mal im Jahr.
Wie?
Ganz selten.
Was trinken Sie?
Ich trinke ganz selten.
Ja, ich habe gehört, was trinken Sie?
Bier oder Wein?
Kommt drauf an.
Unterschiedlich.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Ja.
Aber mittlerweile nicht mehr, weil ich sehr müde bin, wenn ich mich belaste und sehr schnell ausatme.
Ich laufe gerne.
Haben Sie schon mal Drogen konsumiert?
Möchte ich nicht sagen.
Ja, ok.
Nehmen Sie nicht persönlich diese Frage.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Möchte ich nicht sagen.
Möchte ich nicht beantworten.
Ich verstehe Sie.
Aber Drogen kann einige...
Ich nehme aktuell keine Drogen ein.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie eine wichtige Krankheit?
Meine Mutter hat Diabetes.
Mein Vater hat Bluthochdruck.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Einzelkind.
Sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Krankenpflegerin.
Krankenpflegerin.
Sind Sie verheiratet, Frau Kruger?
Nein.
Sie wohnen alleine, ich vermute.
Ich wohn alleine, ich lebe alleine.
Ich habe auch keinen Partner.
Ledig?
Ich habe keinen Partner.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Ok.
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen über Ihre Hautbeschwerde.
Haben Sie Gliederschmerzen?
Gelenkschmerzen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Gelenkschmerzen.
Frau Kruger, möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein.
Ich möchte gerne wissen, was ich habe.
Eigentlich so.
Ich verstehe Sie ganz genau.
Es ist aktuell noch zu früh.
Ich möchte Sie etwas genauer diagnostizieren.
Aber nachher habe ich eine Verdachtung.
Eine Stoffwechselerkrankung oder Herzrhythmusstrung.
Aber es ist wie gesagt nur eine Verdachtung.
Ich möchte Ihnen etwas genauer informieren.
Erst werde ich die Körper untersuchen.
Dann wird ich die Glut entnehmen.
Und dann werde ich die Ergebnisse weiter informieren.
Ok.
Bitte bleiben Sie ruhig.
Es wird gleich weitergehen.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Nein, danke schön. Vielen Dank.
Darf ich fragen?
Ja bitte.
Frau Kruger, Sie haben gesagt monatliche Blutungen verstärkt.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Wie oft und wie lange dauert es?
Es dauert länger als 10 Tage.
Ok. Seit wann?
Seit fast 5 Monaten.
Deswegen haben Sie Ihren Hausarzt besucht.
Vielleicht einen etwas Labor untersuchen.
Nein.
Sehen Sie blass aus?
Ein wenig.
Haben Sie brüchige Nägel bemerkt?
Ja.
Frau Kruger, haben Sie Ohrensausen und Geruch?
Nein.
Können Sie mir die Belastung genau beschreiben?
Wie viele Meter haben Sie?
Wenn ich zügig gehe, wenn ich ein, zwei Stockwerke hochgelaufen bin,
habe ich direkt Belastungsloh.
Ich kann auch nicht mehr joggen.
Das ist schwer für mich.
Ich bin früher mal gelaufen, gejoggt, aber das geht nicht mehr.
Frau Kruger, haben Sie Ihre Beine oder Arme,
das heißt Gefühl und Kriben bemerkt?
Nein.
Ok.
Sie haben die Beine oder Arme nicht mehr bemerkt?
Ach ja, haben Sie auch Ihren Mundwegeriss bemerkt?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Oder große Zunge? Schmerzhafte Zunge?
Das habe ich auch nicht bemerkt, nein.
Ok, danke.
Frau Kruger, wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Essen Sie Fleisch?
Wir kochen gut.
Essen Sie Fleisch oder Vegetarisch?
Ich esse alles.
Ok.
Dann machen wir ein Hartz-Hars-Gespräch.
Ja, weil ich brauche ein paar Minuten.
Ok, dann warten wir noch ein, zwei Minuten.
Darf ich auch eine Frage stellen?
Bitte schön.
Haben Sie auch Ihren Haut einfache Blutungen bemerkt?
Nein.
Nasenblutung, Zähneblutung?
Können Sie mir bitte sagen, wie viele Blutungen brauchen Sie?
Ich meine Hygienische Blutungen.
Ich weiß es nicht, viele.
Mehr als 10 oder 15?
Bestimmt.
Eine große Pakete ist ungefähr 20.
Eine große Pakete brauchen Sie?
Bestimmt.
Und manchmal ist Ihr Haus auch nass geworden?
Nein.
Ok.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es gefragt wurde.
Waren Sie schon beim Frauenarzt?
Zuletzt vor sechs Monaten.
War das damals alles ok?
Er hat gesagt, dass ich einen Myome habe.
Ok.
Danke schön.
Und diese Beschwerden sind zum ersten Mal aufgetreten, oder?
Ja, so habe ich sie vorher noch nie gehabt.
Ok, danke schön.
Seit wann haben Sie gesteigert?
Seitdem sind wir fertig?
Ja.
Dann starten wir jetzt.
Ok.
Guten Tag, Herr Dr. Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Fall.
Bitte schön.
Ich möchte Ihnen sie vorstellen.
Hat sie gesagt?
Ja, bitte schön.
Es geht um Frau Sabine Krüger.
Sie ist 46 Jahre alt.
Sie ist am 22. September 1979 geboren.
Sie ist 1,72 Meter groß.
Sie ist ungefähr 60 Kilo schwer.
Wie?
Sie ist 70 Kilo schwer.
Ok.
Frau Krüger starrte sie heute bei uns
und hat seit mehreren Wochen aufgetreten.
Sie hat Tachikardien und Dyspne.
Sie hat sich vor den Patienten erlaubt,
seit sie sich die Symptome aufgetreten haben,
sich erstmals langsam aufgetreten haben.
Die Patienten klagten über auch Fatiq.
Die Dyspne tritt sich auf.
Die Fragen nach dem Schmerz,
wie es mit der Kalkuline,
der Nervosität,
der Grideschmerzen,
der Chemie,
der Arthralgie und der Fieber,
der Schüttelfreis,
der Nachschweißmixion,
der Defektionsstörung.
Auch Hüsten,
die Emesis wurden verneint.
Die Vekasativanamnese gab
eine vermehrte Schlafstörung
und auch Polyphagie.
Vermehrte Schlafstörung?
Nein, vermehrte Schlaf, ich meine.
Die Reise an der Reise ...
Polyphagie?
Nein, ich habe es fast erklärt.
Ihr Appetit ist gut, ja.
Nicht, dass ihr nicht gut gebraucht habt.
Nicht Polyphagie.
Keine Polyphagie.
Sie hat keine Polyphagie.
Die Reise an der Anamnese
ist unaufällig.
In der Frauenanamnese
gab es Passagiere,
die Menorragie,
die Periode Mesuration
dauerte ungefähr zehn Tage.
Menorragie oder Hypermenoro?
Menorragie oder Hypermenoro.
Hat sie Schmerzen, Beschwerden?
Nein.
Hypermenoro?
Ich weiß, auch Schmerzen bedeutet Schmerzen.
Alles okay.
Ja, beide.
Ja, ist es gleich okay.
Also ...
Nein.
Ja, für eine Frau mit einer Krankheit
sind keine Passagiere
für eine Krankheit.
Für eine Operation
haben die Passagiere
eine Tonsillektum.
Das ist keine Vorerkrankung.
Wie bitte?
Ja, sie hat keine Vorerkrankung.
Ich habe verstanden.
Ich habe eine Vorerkrankung beklagt.
Okay.
Hab ich falsch verstanden.
Ja, okay.
An der Operation gab es die Passagiere
eine Tonsillektum.
Die Tonsillektum
war im Alter von 10 Jahren.
Okay.
Die Medikamenten-Anamnese
war unaufwendig.
Allergien und Unvergesslichkeiten
waren bei der Passagiere unbekannt.
Sie war vollständig.
Sie war vollständig geimpft.
Sie war auch vor zwei Jahren
gegen Covid-19 geimpft.
Die Rauchen
und den Nikotinkonsum
wurden vermeint.
Sie trinken sehr selten
Alkohol.
Ein oder
zwei Mal
in einem Jahr
Hugo oder
Ich habe das nicht
ganz akustisch gehört.
Aber bei der körperlichen Tonsillektum
werde ich wieder nachfragen.
Ja, Hugo oder Scha?
Ich habe das nicht akustisch gehört.
Ja, verstanden.
Was sie trinken.
Ja.
Ist so richtig.
Okay.
Der Drogenkonsum wurde vermeint.
Normalerweise
drei Bezir
jeden Tag Sportlaufe.
Ja, Laufe, aber
wegen Müdigkeit.
Ja.
Können sie nicht viel mehr Sport treiben.
So.
Der Mutter
leider an Diabetes Melutus.
Ja.
Der Vater leider an
arteriale Hypotonie.
Sie sei
Einzelkind.
kranken Pflegerin
von Beruf.
Ledig.
Und sie wohne allein.
Habe keine Kinder.
Die anamnestischen
Angaben
deuten am ehesten auf
die Anamnestik.
Ja.
Die Anamnestik.
Als Differentialdiagnose.
Warum kommen sie auf
die Anamnestik?
Vielleicht begründen sie dafür.
Ja, dafür
sprechen.
Ja, Müdigkeit
und auch Dispne.
Ja.
Und
Hypermenorrhea.
Ja.
Aber
Gründe
für die
Menorrhea habe ich nicht
gefragt.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung
werde ich
nachfragen.
Ja, vielleicht
möglich.
Wahrscheinlich eine
Myoma uteri.
Ja, könnte es sein.
So.
Als
Differentialdiagnosen kommen
Hypertrose
und
so
Herzrhythmusstörungen.
Ja, Arithmy.
Ja, in Betracht.
Oder
Herz
ja
Herzinfizienz in Betracht.
So.
Um die Differentialdiagnose
zu bestätigen,
Differentialdiagnose
auszuschließen,
werde ich folgende
Maßnahmen
durchführen.
Zuerst
werde ich körperliche
Untersuchung durchführen.
Das heißt, ich werde
Vitalparameter
messen.
Um die
Argumente zu beurteilen.
Und auch
bei der körperlichen Untersuchung
achte ich auf
Belese.
Ja.
Und
So.
Ja.
Ja, ich kann
ja, erwarte ich
Belese und Schleimhaut.
Schleimhaut.
Ja.
Ich fahre mir nicht ein
Wort. So.
Ja.
Blasse Schleimhaut. Blasse Haut.
Ja, blasse Schleimhaut. Blasse Haut.
Ja. Ja. Blasse
Haut. Und auch
ich würde
Routenmäßige Herz
und Lungen
Oskutation
durchführen. Ja.
So.
Ich erwarte eine
Ja.
Tachikardie und auch vielleicht
eine
Arithmie.
Ja.
Ja. Können Sie natürlich gucken, aber
Sie sehen ja Blut, ob Sie eine
Arithmie hat oder nicht.
Ja. Dann können Sie das Meiste eigentlich
schon wahrscheinlich
ausschließen.
Genau.
Ja. Natürlich.
Labo Diagnostisch
werde ich Blutbild.
Ja.
TSHast
Tiroi. Ja.
Nehmen Sie den ab am Blut.
Welche Blutwerte
nehmen Sie ab? Ja. Wie bitte?
Welche Blutparameter
nehmen Sie ab? Ah, okay.
Ja.
Ja. So.
Ich werde Blutbild,
kleines Blutbild und
Ferritin. Ja.
Vielleicht Transferrin und
Ja. Müssen Sie nicht sofort machen.
Ja. Ja. Können Sie später machen.
In der Ambulanz müssen Sie das nicht machen.
In der Regel reicht Ferritin,
Eisen müssen Sie auch nicht machen.
Blutbild aus, ne?
Ja. Blutbild. Und gegebenenfalls
ja Ferritin und auch
so
Eis.
Ja. Blutwerte.
Leberwerte, Nierenwerte und auch
TSH
ja, ja.
TSH, gegebenenfalls
T3
T4
Ja.
Entzündungswerte. Ja.
Natürlich Entzündungsparameter. Ja.
Ja.
Bestimmen lassen.
Und auch
in diesem, ja.
Bei
diese
Passanten werde ich
eine EKG
ja.
EKG schreiben.
EKG schreiben. Ja. Ja.
EKG schreiben. So.
Um mögliche
Arithmie
aufzuschließen.
Was ist denn die Therapie von so einer
Eisenmangelanämie?
Ja. Sollte die Verdacht
in der Diagnose
bestätigen.
Ja. Schlag
ich folgende Therapie. Und
als
so. Als
allgemeine
Maßnahmen
ja. Würde ich
den
Passanten
regelmäßige
Frauen
Frauenärzt
Ärzte
Unikologische Vorstellungen.
Ja. Besuchung
empfehlen. Ja.
Und
insbesondere
um
die Gründe.
Nehmen Sie die Patienten nicht stationär
auf oder nicht?
Ja. Stationär aufnehmen.
So.
Bei
schweren
ja.
Schwere
oder. Schwere Anämie.
Ja. Bei schwere Anämie.
Was machen Sie dann?
Therapäutisch? Ja.
Intravenose.
Eisenpräparate
würde ich verabreichen.
Eisen Substitution.
Eisen Substitution. Ja.
Genau. Und
Eisen Substitution.
So.
Manchmal kommt
eine
Transfusion
in Betracht.
Richtig. Weniger.
Ja. Insbesondere weniger als
Hemoglobin
Werte.
Weniger als
Milligramm
pro
Deglitere.
Pro Deglitere.
So. Und auch
als
Medikamentostherapie würde ich
Eisen
Präparate
ja einleiten.
Und so.
Eisenpräparate und
Eisenreiche
Ernährung würde ich
den Patienten empfangen.
Genau so machen wir es.
Sehr gut.
Okay.
Gibt es sonst Fragen?
Man muss in Sivania zuerst auf der
Richtung. Wir haben vergessen zu
Fragen wegen Gynäkologischer
Ananäse.
Ihre Diagnose haben Sie später
umgestellt, weil Sie
wollten zuerst Richtung Herz gehen.
Kardiologische
Diagnose haben Sie gehabt.
Aber die Patientin hat ja nur Beschwerden, wenn sie
Belastung hat. Das ist ganz wichtig.
Und zu Fragen auch
Hautananäse. Haben Sie eine
Hautverfärbung bemerkt?
Haben Sie eine blasse Haut bemerkt?
Das ist immer wichtig bei Frauen.
Nachfragen.
Haben Sie Gynäkologische Vorerkrankungen?
Gibt es bei Ihnen Gynäkologische
Probleme? Wann waren Sie zuerst
beim Gynäkologen?
Ganz, ganz wichtige Frage.
Bei Frauen ist es immer wichtig.
Egal welches Alter.
Erwachsene Frauen immer fragen.
Bei Männern erst ab so 40, 50
Fragen, ob sie beim Orologen
gewesen sind. Aber bei Frauen
immer fragen, waren sie beim Gynäkologen?
Wann zuletzt? Gibt es irgendwelche Besonderheiten?
Sehr gut.
Gibt es sonst Fragen
für diesen Fall? Anmerkungen?
Ja,
wenn sie keine
starke
Regelblutung hatte, wir müssen
auch fragen vielleicht,
wie ist Ihre Eske von Juwenheiten?
Sind Sie vegetarisch oder vegan?
Genau, vollkommen richtig.
Sehr gut.
Kann ja auch sein, dass sie eine Vitamin B
12 Mangel hat bei veganen
Anamnesen.
Diese Frage
hat
schon gestellt werden.
Ja, aber im Genere ist es wichtig
zu fragen,
ob eine besondere Ernährung
vorliegt. Es ist ja auch
Differentialdiagnost. Ich kann ja auch eine
Vitamin B 12 Mangel an
Anamese vorliegen. Oder eine pernitieuse
Anämie zum Beispiel, wenn sie
Magenprobleme hat.
Der Herr Tabakci hat das nicht genannt, aber
als Ergänzung dazu vielleicht.
Es muss nicht immer Eisenmangel an
Anämie sein. Aber bei dieser Patienten
ist Eisenmangel wahrscheinlich
wegen der Biome, wegen
der verstärkten Regelblutung
jeden Monat. Okay, dann
gehen wir zum nächsten Fall.
Soll ich die Aufnahme durchsprechen
oder weitermachen?
Vielen Dank für
Ihre Rückmeldung.